people can go over and under a fence but
you can't take 100 kilos of cocaine over
and under a fence
and what you do when you have limited
places where fences are in populated
areas you force these drug dealers and
others around making it easier to
apprehend because there's fewer places
that come through
ah
joe biden man who used to be for border
hot diggity dog i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report it is september 21st
2022 we're live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv subscribe if you
have not and as some of you who are
playing at home know i am actually in
los angeles right now this is a pre-tape
from yesterday but we're playing it live
today uh because i'm in la i'm doing
bill maher's club random podcast tonight
which obviously will be interesting one
way or another i'm doing some stuff with
prageru uh and i'm joining brian callan
over on his podcast and then tomorrow
thursday i will be dinging the bell at
nasdaq for rumble and we will be live
streaming at 10 a.m for today though
we're going to talk a little bit about
don lemon who just got smacked around
like you would not believe it's so
perfect
just wonderful and then we're going to
do a reubenreport.locals.com
community q a before i get to that let
me talk about talk to you about real
estate agents i trust uh you guys know
that buying or selling a home is already
one of the most stressful things you can
do and it can be 10 times worse if
you're not working with the right agent
usually our homes are our biggest
investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before enjoy
before inviting them to join their
network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction follows you through the
buying or selling process to make sure
that you're satisfied and of course they
only work with agents who have long
track records and are the best sellers
in their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
their own almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to real estate agents
itrust.com and provide them with some
basic info their team will contact you
to make an introduction to a preferred
agent in your town you leave your blue
state you move to a red state you live
happily ever after okay
here we go here is don lemon recently
demoted don lemon this clip is going
bananas viral uh he was covering the
funeral
of uh queen elizabeth and he asked royal
commentator hilary fordwich a question
about reparations this is really rather
extraordinary
well this is coming when you know
there's all of this wealth and you hear
about it comes as england is facing
rising costs of living a living crisis
austerity budget cuts and so on and then
you have those who are asking uh for
reparations for colonialism and they're
wondering you know 100 billion dollars
24 billion dollars here and there 500
million there some people want to be
paid back and
and members of the public are wondering
why are we suffering when you are you
know you have all of this vast wealth
those are legitimate concerns
well i think you're right about
reparations in terms of if people want
it though what they need to do is you
always need to go back to the beginning
of a supply chain where was the
beginning of the supply chain that was
in africa and when that crossed the
entire world when the slavery was taking
place which was the first nation in the
world that abolished
slavery the first nation in the world to
abolish it it was started by william
wilberforce was the british in in great
britain they abolished slavery 2 000
naval men died on the high seas trying
to stop slavery why because the african
kings were rounding up their own people
they had them on cages waiting in the
beaches no one was running into africa
to get them and i think you're totally
right if reparations need to be paid we
need to go right back to the beginning
of that supply chain and say who was
rounding up their own people and having
them handcuffing pages absolutely that's
where they should start and maybe i
don't know the descendants of those
families where they died in the high
seas trying to stop the slavery that
those families should receive something
to i think at the same time
it's an interesting discussion hillary
thank you very much i appreciate it
we'll continue to discuss in the future
we all burst out laughing at the exact
same time there it's an interesting
discussion he has just nothing
nothing to say because what he wants is
britain to be bad the united states to
be bad he wants simple answers white
people bad blah blah blah but it almost
felt didn't that feel like it was a
complete setup by cnn on don lemon like
they gave him the crappier job in the
morning he's now working at night
because they're the special special
event of the funeral
but like they just want to embarrass him
at this point that he asks there's just
no point in asking that question right
now uh as they're burying their queen
and the answer is so clean and clear and
we abolish save slavery first african
kings rounding up their own people i
mean
that was actually my god i can't believe
i'm going to say this every now and
again there is a reason to watch cable
news and it is basically to watch don
lemon get his head clocked i mean just
absolutely incredible let me just say
saying broadly on reparations which i
haven't talked about much on the show a
little bit here and there i am
completely against reparations there is
some argument to be made about
reparations for the people that the
incident happened to it was your you and
your family who directly were the
victims of an attempted genocide let's
say or slavery or whatever it might be
you were kicked out of your house your
community was destroyed something like
that generations later there's simply
nothing that can be done and it's funny
because as lemon lays it out you know
some people want a hundred billion
dollars and then he says 24 billion or
500 million and the thing is
there is no number that will be good
enough you could literally say we will
allocate two trillion dollars for
reparations of all kinds british slavery
american slavery holocaust this that the
other thing
you could say two trillion dollars
everyone will get the exact amount it
will still not stop because it will
never be enough for a certain set of
people people will always want more a
certain set of people will turn on the
people that took it and said you're the
sellout because you take cash in the
name of our dead relatives or whatever
it might be our relatives who are
enslaved uh it's just a terribly bad
idea the world owes you nothing go out
and get yours it's as simple as that i
mean if we were to give out reparations
would would the average uh farmers tax
dollars be going to give don lemon who
is a millionaire
money like does that make any sense i
don't think so okay let's move on to the
reuben report locals community qna big
poppy
says if you had to predict now before
your mar interview what clip take will
go viral what would it be
well i really don't have any idea
because i don't know exactly how much
bill maher knows about me i know he
knows of me i mean they invited me to do
the show so i know there's something
there um you know i've met him a couple
times at parties very briefly i don't
think he has any recollection of that i
actually
interned i think in 1999 or in 2000 they
did politically incorrect which was his
show before real time they did a week
worth of shows on the mafia
this was around sopranos time so a week
worth of shows around the mafia in
brooklyn and i was a i was a pa on the
show i was about to do warm-up and then
something happened i got i got pulled
out on that but
um what clip will go viral look it
depends how political we get
and the producers have told me that the
the feeling of that show of the podcast
is much more personal that he's going to
want to know about me and being married
and a new father and some of the other
things i'm interested in and really get
to know me uh maybe not just all the
political stuff you know beating each
other over the head but if i am able to
discuss one thing with him on the
political side it will sort of be like
okay i get it that you've been
red-pilled to a degree but i know that
you have this sort of um this force
field about around conservatism or
something because
of trump or climate change or something
so it's like is desantis good enough for
you then if you're anti-woke and
anti-gender and
anti-anti-anti-racist and everything
else so we'll hopefully get into it as
much as possible but as i said on the
show yesterday
truly what i would hope more than
anything else is we can just build some
bridges here and it can be the beginning
of a conversation imagine if every
couple weeks even if we aren't in the
same spot ultimately we're able to talk
it out respectfully that would be pretty
good that would be pretty good kat says
uh stuck in a food rut what is a
favorite quick meal that david has made
for you but is kid friendly favor well
first i'll tell you i've been knocking
out a serious meat sauce lately let that
thing uh sit for about five or six hours
on on sundays usually just perfect uh a
quick favorite meal that david has made
for you that well i'll tell you
i i don't know as a father it's uh i'm
too proud to admit that every now and
again david does make me a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich i'm not above the
peanut butter and the jelly but i will
tell you one thing about peanut butter i
can't deal with the peanut butter with
the goo and the slime up top and then
all the good stuff down below and you
got to mix it and it's never ending
mixing it's always dripping all over the
place you get it on you you get it on
your shirt it's no good i like a peanut
butter that has been i don't know if
that's pasteurized or homogenized but i
like a creamy
regular peanut butter
megan says what do you feel would be the
biggest next thing to fundamentally
change our future digital currency
energy crisis food crisis what can and
should we prepare for well it does seem
like they're going to push this climate
crisis on us that kovid was really a
test for what the people
will accept and a certain amount of
people kind of like lockdowns a certain
amount of people kind of like getting
injected with stuff a certain amount of
people like wearing masks like they
could just make us all feel crazy again
the sun's rays are now two percent
stronger than they used to be and blah
blah blah blah blah and then they'll get
all the experts on and then if you say
actually i do want to walk outside every
now and again and i would like some
sunshine they'll you're a right-wing
maniac racist
like the the plot is already all in
front of us so i don't know what it's
going to be i think the digital currency
thing is super dangerous if it's
centralized obviously which is why
decentralized you know bitcoin is so
important uh that's one thing i think
that obviously the environment is where
they're going to really go
um but it's like they could pull off
anything like a grid going down so then
there's energy crisis you know that sort
of thing
you know get the war to be hot again and
you you know ukraine it's like you know
right now there's these like stories i
don't even talk about them on the show
because it all feels
impossible to really understand what's
going on but they're kind of like
ukraine's winning it's like well okay
well but russia's not going to lose
because they have nukes so where do you
think this thing's going to end up so
there's a whole bunch out there anyway
get a little water have a little water
have a solar charger for your phone
freedom lover says hey dave what are you
planning on doing for the high holidays
this year fly dennis prager in
zoom his services or have you found
someplace local healthy happy and
prosperous new year to you and your
entire family thank you shana toba to
you as well rosh hashanah is the the
jewish new year uh which is next week so
we're not going to have live shows on
rosh hashanah or yom kippur which i
haven't done in the last couple years
and i've gone to services in l.a that
dennis prager holds uh this year we have
found a community we're going to go uh
first and have a nice meal over at my
sisters who's going to do some cooking
and she just had her third baby but
we're going to get all the kids together
and see what happens and then i'll try
to zoom in on on dennis's services which
i think they do put out on zoom i've
mentioned many times that these services
that dennis holds
where he gets i mean it's a huge crowd
probably five or six hundred people he
makes it purely apolitical which is
obviously great although by me being
there and then dennis being there
afterwards you know people are kind of
congregating in the in the parking lot
trying to trying to talk politics last
year everyone was trying to talk recall
election and what's going to happen um
but uh he has definitely helped me
connect to that part of my my history
and my family and all of that stuff and
that's just great so i hope that
whatever you're doing you'll do it with
an apple and some honey as well uh ellen
says how do we convince our woke gay son
that we are not the faces of evil
it's not easy i don't have to tell you
that ellen um look you know
unfortunately the gays in some way as a
community and i don't like community and
i think lgbt none of that makes any
sense i have nothing to do
or no more in common with a trans person
than a straight person does right it's a
completely different thing
but for young people especially they've
combined somehow gay which once was
irreverent and cool and outside of the
box and that's why so much music and art
and culture came out of the gay scene
and it had its problems too right you
take a whole bunch of people you don't
let them get in lasting relationships
then you're gonna have a whole bunch of
drugs and you're gonna have a bunch of
stds and all of that stuff then you get
equality and it's like time to move on
guys like that i thought that's what we
were fighting for um
so i don't know exactly what you do i
guess maybe you could try to show them
this show or something else about me or
me talking about this sort of thing and
maybe that'll get him to wake up a
little bit
but i have major major sympathy for you
i can say it as a as a
as a new father especially i suppose
that you know one day your kid could
turn to you and be like you're evil
because you don't believe what i believe
or you're a bigot or or you should have
done this that the other thing
i can't imagine what that's like i have
a lot of sympathy
but i guess if you just keep trying to
be a good person
hey i want you to find someone in life
to
be happy with i hope you have a family
or whatever you want and you just keep
trying i guess that's that's the best
you can do will says when are you going
to get an ar-15 i don't know when i'm
going to get an ar-15 but a couple weeks
ago we took the whole team shooting and
i did shoot an ar-15 and an ak-47 i like
them i like them a lot and we're going
to keep doing that sort of thing mia
says i am volunteering for the
republican party of new mexico knocking
on doors and passing out palm cards and
yard signs what are the top three
conservative points i should focus on
making when speaking with democrats you
always articulate my thoughts for me so
well i'm having trouble coming up with
something concise and perfect you know i
won't give you three here but i'll give
you the bullet one which is if you're
meeting somebody that is a new democrat
or or they're they're a democrat but you
think maybe they're on the fence or you
think you can convince them
just say something like this you don't
have to attack them like don't make it
about abortion don't make it about
something that's gonna like right off
the bat we're all going to go crazy
right
how about
do you feel the government did a good
job over the last couple years do you
feel that the systems that we were
supposed to trust were worthy of being
trusted do you think that the people who
either locked us down or put us in masks
or made us get injections while at the
same time telling us our body our choice
when it came to other issues do you
think that any of this made sense so the
basic argument would be how about just
less resources and money and attention
to those people and if you kind of think
that's right well the republicans maybe
aren't great some of them are pretty
good maybe they're not great i don't
know enough about internal new mexican
politics but i bet you they're better
than the democrats i bet you they want
lower taxes than the democrats i bet you
they're more police more for police and
law and order than the democrats the
basic stuff and if you do that in a way
that just how about your life would you
like more money in your pocket or less
do you want more government involvement
in business or less do you think the
government after two years of covet is
really great when it comes to health
insurance or not and i think if you do
sort of like really think about it from
your perspective i think that's probably
the best way to get them uh blue says we
know dave loves good tequila do you have
a favorite margarita recipe that you can
share i mean off the top of my head the
the third third third is probably the
easiest way to go you do a third tequila
a third lime juice and a third orange
juice it's like the simplest one do that
on the rocks
uh and and you're basically good to go
some people say a third lime juice is a
bit much a little too tart so you can
mess with it i'd maybe up the tequila
down the orange juice frankly and i like
something a little tart i like the
citrus there and
enjoy yourself wayne says do you think
elon is ever going to buy twitter i
don't know and in a weird way i don't
care at this point honestly i know that
kind of sucks and i spent a lot of time
talking about it it's a little hard to
figure out what's what and when where
that whole thing is going but i know
that huge amounts of twitter accounts
are fake i know the conversation there
is completely butchered i don't know
that he can fix it i don't i think it
may be beyond repair and i think maybe
we have to let it fail and you know what
then you build new things which is
exactly why uh tomorrow i will be
dinging the bell as rumble slash locals
go public because we have to build
better things instead of relying on
these old things that were designed
really to abuse us not to make us more
social or anything else
amy says what are you most looking
forward to or what are you hoping to
achieve during your time with bill maher
well i sort of answered that already but
really the best takeaway is not going to
be some sort of knockout punch and he's
going to be like i love republicans it's
just not going to happen and i don't
even know that that's what i would want
to do the best
takeaway is that there is a mutual
respect there after an hour and a half
and that we say okay how about we
continue this conversation bill you come
on my show every couple weeks every
other month whatever it is we talk about
what's going on i'll go on your show or
i'll go on real time uh they've canceled
me a couple times but i'll do that and
then
it's like let's see if because the point
ultimately is
if bill maher and dave rubin
two guys that let's say we were old
school liberals ten years ago the whole
left went woke okay now we've shifted a
little bit but if we can't get to that
common ground then the country really
doesn't have a chance because we have
way more in common than we have a part
and if i'm just a little bit ahead of
him on that red pill adventure or maybe
he uh thinks that i have a blind spot
when it comes to something like we
should be able to do that so if we can
do that then something good will have
come out of it
seven says if the usa became a monarchy
who would you want to be king or queen
well how about uh if i could reincarnate
somebody you give me uh johnny carson as
king you know what i mean like a little
johnny carson as king everybody loved
johnny carson he wasn't crazy political
that's what you need out of a king
somebody that everyone just kind of
likes he's funny he's pleasant
i did not know that
weird wild stuff that would be good
maybe lucille ball as queen
nick says uh you've talked to jordan
peterson about how you no longer believe
that you are the exception to the rule
of needing to become a father in order
to live a fully actualized life do you
think that the energetic king of late
night just might be that exception
that's a great question on a couple
fronts so you're referring to greg
gutfeld who uh who does not have kids uh
you guys know my feelings on this i i
was on tour with jordan and he kept
repeatedly talking about the importance
for most people not everybody to live
that fully actualized life to have a
child that it is just part of the human
experience it is so fundamentally part
of it that pretty much everyone needs it
and he would make a point not everybody
i actually think to some degree
i was close i was really probably an
edge case on this in terms of my life
has been great the last couple years
i've been in a great relationship i meet
great people i do great things i wake up
every day with purpose for work
and i love what i'm doing and i think
i'm making a difference and people
respond well to me and it's given me a
good life and all those things so i was
i think as close maybe as i could get to
it but i think perhaps something was
missing in there and i think i see it
every morning when i grab justin out of
his out of his little bed and we take
our walk in the morning and all that um
as for gut felt i can't speak to him
speak for him specifically on this but
gutfeld all the things that i just
described about myself i think he's
feeling for himself um i don't know all
the the personal side of that so um i
can discuss it with him and maybe get
back but i think gutfeld's he's a happy
dude he loves what he's doing he's fun
he's a great guy too gut felt when i
hang out with him after the show it's
like same exact thing same guy just uh
well usually with a couple of drinks but
same guy okay let me do this real quick
because i got to get on this plane stacy
says dave who do you think really
controls the white house teleprompter
scripts a team of consensus or one
particular driving force
it's the million dollar question who is
running the show who's typing the words
that the old guy reads poorly i do not
know
and uh it's got to be some kind of obama
related something or other let's not
forget obama what did he say in that 60
minutes interview a couple years ago
what would be his dream to basically
have a puppet that he could be talking
to through his ear so
sudo says do you know if the rumble
leadership on the public investment side
of things has discussed how to avoid the
influence of esg or woke investors well
hopefully i can talk about this a little
bit more over the next couple weeks as
more and more things are announced with
rumble but what i can tell you for sure
is that everyone that i have been around
at rumble from chris the ceo up top to
all of the other executive team and dan
bongino and me and everybody else like i
don't think a company has ever gone
public with this many people fully for
free
expression fully to defend free speech
and be a neutral platform and deal with
the headaches that come with that so um
i think there's a real chance here
that's that's just what i believe um i
don't think there's a perfect system but
i know we there's never been a company
as far as i know that has gone public
with such a group of people who have
dedicated themselves to fighting the
machine fighting big tech and building a
better internet which is the thing that
we've all freaking wanted this entire
time all right one more for you today
and then we're going to los angeles i'm
in los angeles right now god it's weird
uh terry says what interview have you
enjoyed the most
this year um
well it's a little bit of reverse but i
loved coming back with larry elder just
a couple weeks ago first off it was the
first thing that we did in our local
studio it was great to see larry it was
good to be back nothing shocked me that
much
i love larry i think we've just such a
great thing going together and he's just
so he's just an absolute pro like wasn't
he just great at it like laying out the
ideas not giving too much of his opinion
in them so that i could respond to them
properly
just great and i'll throw in one more
because i just did it and i think it'll
be up uh later today oh no part one is
already up actually if i'm not mistaken
uh south carolina uh senator tim scott
who's just a good dude like one of these
people you're like what are you doing in
politics man you're just a good
decent human being
i really enjoyed uh chatting with him so
there you go all right i am in la right
now
i'm sending i'm talking to you from the
future or something like that uh but
tomorrow thursday remember the live
stream will be at 10 a.m from nasdaq
floor and if you can get to a tv or
wherever they live stream this story
that sort of stuff i'm dinging the bell
for rumble at 9 30 a.m
with the executive team over there super
excited about it if you want to play
along at home reuben report.locals.com
as i said part one of that interview
with tim scott is up across platforms
right now and we leave you with a cold
clothes our children our children their
children so our children our children
our children children little children
about the children the children the
children the children i always think
about the children
our children our children our children
our children our children their children